- I next have to invite myself up
to give a brief chat about
visual culture computation
in the Digital Humanities lab,
and what we've been doing
over the last couple years.
Almost everything I'm gonna show today
in my talk is actually a team effort.
It involves user experience
design from Monica Ong Reed,
it involves some incredibly
sophisticated programming
from Doug Duhaime from
whom you'll hear later.
It involves a lot of
planning organization advice
feedback from Cathy DeRose from
whom you'll also hear later.
So I just wanna preface that by saying
what I'm gonna show
you today is the result
of a laboratory coming together
of trying to build reusable for folks
in the cultural heritage space.
And so that's what I'm
gonna focus on today,
focus on the problem of
visual culture computation
and I think, if I'm not misremembering,
I think this is actually a
term that Catherine Haskins,
who's in the audience today
asked us to think about.
My own background as well as that of Doug,
and Cathy and others in the lab
is actually really
textural, so we have degrees
in literature of some kind and
coming to Yale for all of us
was this really amazing experience
because we started to think about
the world-class physical holdings
that included oil paintings
and medieval manuscripts
and sculptures and things
which would never be reducible
down to Unicode text.
So all the things I
had done on my post-doc
of text mining Google Books,
suddenly I'm in a world
where I've got RGB pixel values,
I've got 3D data from sculptures,
it was really exciting challenge
that Catherine and others,
including our Dean of Humanities
laid out for us in the
lab, to be responsive
to visual culture and so
what I'm gonna show you today
is gonna be some steps towards that.
What I'm really gonna try
to focus on is the problem of scale.
So the notion of
collection-scale analysis,
collection-scale experience
is really important to us.
And that's because I think
none of us want to interfere
with the traditional art historical praxis
of sitting in front of an
amazing oil painting at YCBA
or looking at archival photographs,
that's how I was trained
as an undergraduate
in our history, that will always go on.
What we're trying to enable
with visual culture computation
is methods and approaches
which are impossible
once you reach the scale of 10s
or 100s of 1000s of objects.
And in order to start this conversation
I wanna give my very
basic attempt at talking
about some of the principles
of machine vision.
There's really no better
person in this room
than me, the PhD in Swedish literature
to talk about machine vision
and deep convolutional
networks, I can't tell you
how much I'm looking forward to this.
But what I wanna start is
with an interactive thing,
is if you have a cell
phone, usually people say,
put away the cell phone,
take out your Android,
take out your iPhone and just
go to your photo library.
And doesn't matter if you use Android
or you use Google Photos, if
you have photos on your phone,
doesn't matter, you'll
either find a search box
at the top or bottom left,
sometimes you have to pull down.
I'm just gonna recommend
that you type the word cat.
Cats are my favorite example for this
and in my example I have
254 pictures of cats.
These are generally my sister's cat,
sometimes they're librarians
cats here at Yale.
And if you don't have a
cat you could try dog,
you could try kid, you
could try car, bicycle,
whatever you think you
might take pictures of.
No matter if you use Google Photos,
if you use IOS, you're gonna find
what you're looking for I hope.
And you can ask then what's going on?
And why am I seeing pictures
that I have never labeled?
This isn't Flickr, I haven't
described these things,
I haven't hired a processing archivist
from the Beinecke to
expertly describe this.
So who decided these were
cats and how did that happen?
And the answer of
course, is that all of us
on our phones or in the cloud depending on
how your architecture is,
Google does it in the cloud,
Apple does it on the phone.
There's a convolutional neural network,
which is captioning or
describing everything
you take a picture of.
And this is really powerful,
it means I don't have to
go and label my pictures,
in fact, I don't even think
there is a way to label my
pictures on my cell phone, right?
You take a picture and you
can then search for it.
So this is very powerful, very exciting
and all of this, although
theorized many years
or even decades previously really
only hit the real world around 2012
when a convolutional
neural network was able to
solve a image description
challenge in a way
that was significantly better than
other image captioning algorithms in 2011.
And so you can see around
2012 that something changed
and it meant that we started
getting these systems,
which trained on categories
like cat and dog and chair
and bagel and banana would be
able to describe those things.
And so this is what's running
now in all of our cell phones
whether we want it to or not.
So this is really exciting, why don't we
take these systems which can describe cat
so effectively, which can
find bagels and skateboards,
why don't we take these
machine vision systems
from companies like Google
or Amazon or Facebook
and let them loose on
our cultural heritage?
There's truly nothing that
could go wrong here, right?
And so I just got back from a brief talk
in Sydney in Australia
and so I was interested
in this idea of let's use machine vision
to catalog Australia's visual heritage,
so I went to an Australian history website
and I took an image, the first one I saw,
and I put it through probably
the best machine vision API,
the Google Cloud Vision
API, this is absolutely,
100% gonna give me the right answer.
So I gave it the image, and I said,
could you describe what this is?
And it told me that it
was a fashion accessory,
probably jewelry, with little
less certainty possibly earrings,
but maybe body jewelry or silver.
So let's actually go to the source
and figure out what these are.
Well, these are leg manacles of course
from Australia's convict
history and actually the fact
that Google would recognize them as such
is not something that I invented,
it's something that a curator in
the Smithsonian told me
based on some experience.
You can only imagine the valence of this
in an American context with
African American slavery.
So what happened, what went wrong?
Well, really, this isn't Google's fault,
and this is not Amazon's
fault, it has to do with
the kinds of usage and captions that
off-the-shelf captioning
systems optimize for.
They generally optimize for the cats
that I'm taking pictures of or the cars
or the bicycles, contemporary
images from 2019.
Images which are captured on cell phones,
so we tend to take single
pictures of cute cats
on our cell phones, that's
what we use 'em for.
And crucially I think
monetizable use-cases.
It wouldn't surprise me if
Facebook has a recognizer
if I upload a picture of
myself drinking a Coke,
they can probably sell me an ad of Pepsi
next time I log in based
on some brand recognition,
that wouldn't surprise me at all.
The training and the categories
make all the difference
and if there is bias, it's
in the training categories
and the captions and the data,
not necessarily inherently
in the linear algebra.
This horrific justification
of a piece of metal
that is connected with a
convict or with a slave history
depending on which country you're in
is not the only unexpected
juxtaposition of visual culture
and in fact artists like Fred Wilson
working many years ago in the early '90s
at the Baltimore Country
Museum put together
a terrific exposition that
was called, Mining the Museum.
And Mining the Museum is
exactly what Yale professor
in American studies and women's,
gender, and sexuality studies Laura Wexler
thought of when she saw this juxtaposition
of convict shackles from Australia
being described as jewelry.
She thought of Fred Wilson's installation
within Mining the Museum
called, "Metalwork."
And so I wanna acknowledge Laura's point
and I was able to find an
image of slave shackles
here we're in the American
context, the Southern context
at the bottom center of this image
juxtaposed by artist Fred
Wilson with some of the other
elements and material
culture from Baltimore
and Maryland broadly,
the production of which
was of course enabled by slave labor.
So as we encounter these
unexpected or horrific
miscaptions in our
convolutional neural networks,
it is I think as we try to fix that,
worthwhile thinking about what such
unexpected juxtapositions
might trigger in our own minds
and I think that that
may be what Fred Wilson
was doing in an analog way
back in the early '90s.
So as we turn away from some brief notions
of convolutional neural
networks in how they see
and how they describe the world,
I wanted to then move
on to three experiments
with visual culture
computation that try to get
around this problem,
that try to use the power
of what industry can give us whether
from Amazon or Facebook or Google.
Take these pre-trained
networks and in some way
shift them and distort them to serve
the needs in cultural
heritage institutions,
perhaps natural science institutions,
what are the ways that we
can take the advancements
that are allowing me to
find all the cats I've ever
taken pictures of, but not
miscategorize the 19th century
or describe something in a
way that's very inappropriate.
So we're gonna start with the first one,
which is specifically can
these pre-trained captioning
networks be useful
without their categories?
And in order to answer
that question we took
a collection which is actually split
between the Yale Beinecke Rare
Book and Manuscript Library
and the National Portrait
Gallery in the Smithsonian.
The majority of the collection
physically is in the Beinecke
and then there's some very
important Mathew Brady negatives
that are at the National Portrait Gallery.
It's one of the largest private
collections of 19th century
photography from the 1860s to the 1890s,
the Civil War to the Gilded Age.
And it's an incredibly rich
and powerful collection
to look through, it's famous
for its depictions of Lincoln.
There's a problem though,
it doesn't include any cats.
And as we know these
convolutional neural networks
are only good at finding cats.
So we have this mismatch
between our source data
and the networks which are really good
at describing the world.
And so the impetus behind
trying to fix that problem,
behind trying to find a
way that these networks
could still be useful, but in a world
where they weren't trying to
describe things too explicitly
has actually resulted in
this demonstration here,
so what I have here on the screen are
just a couple images from the
Meserve-Kunhardt Collection.
There actually isn't too
much import in which ones
are on the screen right
now, this is a random sample
from our Civil War collection.
What maybe is a little
bit more interesting
is the ability to take this website
and do something with my mouse,
so I'm gonna move my mouse over
this dude here on the left.
And when I move my mouse over him,
I'm gonna get images which
are visually similar to him
and when I move my mouse over this guy
I'm gonna get images which are
visually similar to that one,
move my mouse over a guy in an oval,
I'm gonna get images also
in that same oval vignette.
Let's go to another image, I
dunno if anybody likes boats,
we got some boats, like
houses, we got houses.
Now in some cases these
are actual literal reprints
and that's okay, it's a large collection,
reprints were made for
a long period of time.
In some cases we know
what these things are,
we have captions and this happens
to be Lincoln's house in Springfield.
Sometimes we know who this person was,
we know it in one image
on the bottom right,
but not on the top left.
So those are reprints, but what I think
is more interesting than the reprints
is the notion of the pictorial
conventions of depiction here.
So what I can do by surfing
through this website
is look at how people were depicted
in various ways based
on visual similarity.
And the visual similarity
actually has a lot to do
with the convolutional
neural networks that we
were talking about before
and this project is based on
pre-trained convolutional neural networks
which are designed to find
skateboards, bagels, and cats.
But in this artificial vision system
which starts with very simple discoveries
about maybe lines or small shapes
and evolves all the way into
this is a cat or this is a dog,
we step back from that final layer,
and we take the penultimate,
the semi-final layer
in the network, which gives us
about 2,048 abstract dimensions of sight.
There's really no way to
describe these 2,048 ways
of seeing except that they are crucial
in distinguishing cats from skateboards.
In that sense it kind of solves
the futurization problem for us,
we get a pre-trained model,
we shift it to do something else,
we have this relatively
high dimensional space,
2,048 ways of seeing, so think about
one dimension of x, y, z, and
then 2,045 more dimensions
that I don't have letters for.
We can do math in that
high dimensional space.
We can use a proximus
nearest neighbors algorithm
to find the images which are the closest
to a given image that
I'm moving my mouse over
in these other dimensions,
and that's what results
in all these other pages
of writing showing up,
perhaps because there's one dimension
which was responding to a white background
and another dimension which
was responding to squiggles,
put that together you
get basically all the
archival handwritten
documents in the collection.
So we are basically taking
pre-trained networks,
but intercepting them
and using them to surface
other images of women in
sort of interesting ways.
What I think this tool really gives you
is the kind of way to surf through,
by starting with one image
and discovering conventions
of portraiture in a time when
exposure times were long,
people took a good deal of
time getting dressed up,
sometimes their bodies were
even stabilized by metal stands,
so a lot of thought went into
these conventions of depiction.
All right, so that is neural neighbors
and my favorite example from
this particular data set
which George Miles helped
bring to the Beinecke,
I call it the pugilist example,
so I've moved my mouse
over a boxer in the bottom
and I get all the other boxers,
and what you'll notice here is that
one intuition is that the
network is more responsive
to line than it is to tone,
and that's one theory.
And this might explain
why it doesn't matter
if the boxer is facing left or right,
nor does it matter if the boxer
is Caucasian or African
American, now there may
or may not be an explicit
category in the Beinecke's
own expert cataloging
of the Meserve-Kunhardt
Collection of pugilist, but
it doesn't really matter
because we've built a
virtual subject category
by relying on the conventions
or portraiture in this
particular collection.
So that's Neural Neighbors
and that's open-source
software that people
can use, in fact we're
pushing this tool forward
to help solve some problems
that might be familiar for those who know
about the Farrows
Collection of photography
and we're also pushing that
in a couple different directions.
We wanna make this available
for anybody to use,
it's all open science, we
didn't invent these algorithms
we just sort of put it together.
And we also wanted to go further,
and so the second technique
I'm gonna talk to you about
actually builds on the
idea of I have one image
and I wanna see everything
which is similar
to it in my collection.
Using that intuition of
using pre-trained networks,
but stepping back from the final category
and going to a semi-final
layer which is more abstract,
can we use that more abstract space
as a way of organizing the
entire collection en mas.
So this gets to what I
was talking about earlier,
the collection-scale analysis,
or collection-scale visualization.
And so we have another
software product out there
called PixPlot, and it actually
uses some of the same math
that we just talked about,
pre-trained networks,
discard the layers which
are optimized for 2019,
take the penultimate layer,
and then we have the same
dimensionality reduction problem.
We need to somehow
visualize 2,048 dimensions
in our web browser and
that's really tough to do
with two-dimensional screens,
so dimensionality reduction
is basically like the
idea of taking a flower
and pressing it between
the leaves of a book.
You as a human are able to figure out,
how best can I crush this flower
and still preserve its distinctive shape.
It's pretty easy for a
human to do that from
three dimensions to two dimensions.
To do it from 2,048 dimensions
down to two dimensions
takes more math, and there are
a whole bunch of techniques,
something as simple as
principle component analysis,
something more advanced like t
Stochastic Neighbor Embedding
or tSNE and then a really cool,
new algorithm called UMAP,
Uniform Manifold
Approximation and Projection,
they're always a minimizing loss,
minimizing what you're
destroying by crushing
that flower from three
dimensions to two dimensions.
And now we have a two-dimensional space
if we're successful in this reduction
and we somehow now have to show you
a lot of images all at the same time.
I'll show you how this works here.
And for this demo I thought maybe with
the permission of Manuel
to show some images
from the Yale Center for British Art.
So we've taken about 31,000 images
as we know the Yale Center for British Art
was a pioneer in putting
non-copyright encumbered images
online for anybody to work with
and so we benefit from that generosity
and I'm able to take all of
those images they gave me
and throw them on the floor.
But they haven't landed randomly.
They've landed in such a way that images
that share the same visual characteristics
have landed on the
floor at the same place.
So I'm sure there's a
technical word for these,
I call them the caricatures of dandies.
These are all the
well-dressed men in very nice
clothing down here at the
bottom left of my visualization.
This visualization is in
fact the result of a UMAP
production of 2,048 dimensions
into two dimensions.
And what I'm doing here
is showing this reduction
and hopefully UMAP has
been effective at keeping
images that look like
each other near each other
in this much reduced dimensional space.
It isn't just these guys, we also have,
anybody here like animals,
let's go to the zoo,
here's the zoo, and it's everybody
from horses to camels and
things like that on my screen.
There are some other
really interesting things
which show characteristics of YCBA data.
All the vignetted sketches.
My favorite one may be since we have
some natural scientists in the room,
is that there's this really cool
cluster of botanical illustration.
I'm sure there's a category
for this in the explicit
metadata at YCBA, I just
think it's kinda cool
that this thing just all
landed in the same place.
And then finally, there's
some cool stuff down here.
The Yale Center for British Art of course
justifiably considers frames to be artwork
in and of themself, so we have
some really terrific frames here.
What I love about his is
these images of frames
are close to this other cluster of images
where the frame is too
big, really in my opinion,
so it's Frameville, right,
we're in Frameville.
But we have this enormous visualization.
People sometimes use
metaphors of this looks like
a constellation, it looks
like an archipelago of islands
and things like that, but
this is what anybody can do
if you load your pictures into PixPlot.
We recommend at least 5 to 10,000 images.
We are pushing PixPlot forward
in some interesting ways.
It is primarily authored by Doug Duhaime
and so I do want to acknowledge his work
in programming this in
WebGL which is a way
of programming websites
that's more akin to writing
a 3D video than using HTML tags.
That's the reason we're able to get
really high performance out of this.
But what I wanna do is to
talk about another example
from my own research, I'm gonna
give you about 30,000 pictures from
the Southern Swedish city
of Lund in Scandinavia
and so we're gonna have these images
which were taken by two photographers
just to show you how this
works on photography.
So we have these unexpected clusters.
These are all sort of from
the early 20th century.
Turns out people liked taking
pictures of kids in chairs
in the early 20th century in Sweden.
These are all these kids in chairs.
I had no idea this was a genre,
and it's nearby the cluster
of standing children,
so I guess as a parent you could decide
do I want my kid standing
up for their portrait
or do I want them in a chair?
There's other examples
here, turns out marriages
cohere pretty well, these
are wedding pictures, right?
There's women in white gowns.
And there's also something kind of cool
I wanted to show you which
is we've got pictures
of buildings here in
the center of my screen,
pictures of parks down here,
and what's between buildings and parks,
turns out to be buildings in parks.
So there was originally
probably one dimension
which was responding to the
grass and trees in parks
and there was another
dimension that was responding
to the linearity, the roof
lines, the walls of houses
or buildings and UMAP, a
dimensionality reduction algorithm
was able to somehow
collapse these two lines
into a much smaller space that
still preserves the spectrum.
I wanna show you a really
early alpha version of PixPlot
which accomplishes something
even more exciting.
In this demo is going to be showing you
the interrelationship
between human metadata
and what the computer sees.
So of course when I was dealing with the
Yale Center for British Art images,
I was not taking into account who
painted that or who drew that.
And what we're doing with
the new version of PixPlot
is being able to pull these
explicit metadata edges
like who drew this, who wrote this,
who painted it, what year was it,
and put that into conversation with
some of our visualization, so
the first thing I'll show you
is that we do have the
ability to think about these
images in a variety of
dimensionality reductions,
this is just the most
banal, this is just all
the images one by one by
one, that's pretty cool.
But before we were showing you
a couple different
dimensionality reductions,
now I can show you the
animation between them.
So we might have for example these images,
which are about 30,000
orienting themselves
into a t-SNE reduction, which is
just one way of organizing them.
We can do that with
another dimension added in,
and you're seeing about 30,000 objects
move all at the same time
on your screen in WebGL.
T-SNE has managed to orient these down
in a way that here's the neighborhood
of those kids in chairs, so we still
have that clustering, right?
Each algorithm will put the
stuff in different parts
of your screen and there is
a stochastic or random aspect
to each visualization,
so we don't want people
to take these as
deterministic, we just want
them to take them as suggestive,
and in fact that's one of
the reasons we've moved
towards this animation engine.
So that people can see that
all of these arrangements
are really contingent, and
there are different ways
of thinking about the data
that are all legitimate.
This is UMAP, one of our most exciting
visualizations 'cause it
certainly clusters things
in a certain way, but I think
what I wanted to show you here
was this interrelationship
between the metadata,
who took this picture, and the algorithm,
which sees the notion
of children in chairs.
So what I can do with
this version of PixPlot
is I can say turn off a
particular photographer.
Only show me pictures by Per Bagge
or only show me pictures by Ida Ekelund.
Now when I do that most of the images
of children in chairs disappear.
There's still this cluster
of children in chairs,
but if I turn off Per Bagge,
and only show you Ida Ekelund
then what I get is a much reduced cluster
whereas if I switched to Per Bagge,
here indeed are all the kids in chairs.
And so what this tells you is there's
a substantial difference between
the output of these two
photographers who worked in
the same building and trained
with the same woman in Lund,
and they were active at the same time,
but this woman did not
shoot babies in chairs,
that wasn't her bag.
She actually shot a lot of images
of women in their 20s and
30s with very short hair
and in the American context
you would think of these people
as flappers, so there's a
separate cluster of flappers
that only Ida Ekelund took pictures of.
That's one of the things
that we can discover
when we put machine vision in conversation
with the explicit
metadata edges of who took
this picture, and when did they take it.
Another exciting thing
about the future of PixPlot
is that we want to turn this
into a tool for curators.
Pretend we were going to that zoo area
we were looking at before, and you say,
hey, I'm really interested in horses,
so I'm gonna trust the
algorithm to cluster
all the animals together 'cause it seems
to do a pretty good job of that,
but I don't want any
camels in my collection
'cause I'm preparing an exhibit on horses.
And so what we can do is let
you have a kind of lasso,
remember you're in Photoshop or Paint
and you're trying draw a
complex shape around something,
so what we'll allow you
to do is draw your own
circle or your own lasso shape around
just the horses that you like, you'll be
able to Shift + select, deselect.
And then what do you do with that stuff,
well you might download it as a CSV file,
you might bounce it into a PowerPoint,
you might upload it to Omeka,
you might just have a list of things
you need to take a closer look at.
So being able to put
the human intuition into
a conversation with a way
that the machine vision
is organizing these images
we think is really exciting.
We wanna work with human
expertise not against it.
I think that's my main takeaway.
I have five minutes left and now I wanna
show you something kind of edgy.
I like to think of this as if,
have you ever been working
on a book manuscript
or an article or a student evaluation?
And you've been working on this
for like every day this week,
your book or your article or whatever,
maybe you're reorganizing your closet.
And it's all you can do all day,
and when you go to bed
there's this horrible thing
when you start dreaming about the chapter
you're trying to write during
the day, it will not leave you.
And we were thinking that
we're making some of this
Nvidia hardware and these convolutional
neural network software
work really hard all day.
We run these jobs for seven
or eight days in a row,
multiple GPUS in the cube over there.
And we thought well, what happens when
these neural networks go off the shift
when it's five p.m.,
what do they dream about?
Do they start hallucinating about all
these portraits they've
been seeing during the day?
And so what we wanted to do was explore
the notion of generative models.
And generative models are of course
a form of unsupervised machine learning
and the notion is that given enough
ground truth, given enough training data
of things as they are in the world,
algorithms might be able
to come to an understanding
of a probability distribution
of the characters
in the words of a book or the pixel values
in a 19th century portrait.
And we might be able to
sample from these networks
and produce new objects which have
never existed in the world before.
If you read in the Times
or the Washington Post
articles about deepfakes, that's actually
what's going on here,
they're generative models.
And so what I'm gonna show you today,
a notion of generative
adversarial networks.
Now the cool thing about
generative adversarial networks
is actually two networks working in tandem
or more accurately working
adversarial to one another.
Generative adversarial networks
consist of two networks, an art forger
who is shown images of
10s of 1000s of objects
and does its best to invent
or hallucinate new things.
There's a joke here about
then selling the forged object
to the Getty here, which I won't make
'cause we have somebody in the Getty here.
The detective though is
working for the art museum
and he or she is looking
at all these objects
and trying to discern which
one actually existed in
the real world and which ones
were dreamt up by the forger.
And what's interesting
about this interrelation
is that each of these two neural networks
pitted against each
other in an adversarial
relationship learns from its mistakes.
If the forger does not get an
image through the detective
then it says, well I screwed
up and I gotta do better.
Let me go back to the ground
truth and try to learn
a better prior, a better
probability distribution
of RGB pixels or characters.
If the detective accidentally lets
a fake Greek sculpture
through it then says
I should never do that
again, let me revisit
my ideas about what is
real, and what is fake,
and all this happens 10s
of 1000s times a second
and we run these for
days and days and days.
So this is what happens when we ran
a generative adversarial network
on the Meserve-Kunhardt Collection
of faces from this 19th century,
Civil War, Gilded Age collection.
What you're seeing is the
output of the generator
fighting against the discriminator
trying to arrive at some
kind of consensus on what
a 19th century face looks like.
And now some people when they
see this they think it is
uncanny, some people think
it's like a horror movie
or something, but you're
seeing in real time,
the result of two neural networks fighting
each other over the definition of a face.
It doesn't understand what a face is.
But that's how we interpret as humans.
You'll sometimes see faces
that are split in half.
I have another example here I'll show you,
this is the same algorithm running
those Swedish pictures
I showed you earlier.
And these are about 30,000 faces.
And so you'll see these two
networks fighting each other
and what you'll find there on the left
if you look on the
right side of the screen
I have some samples
drawn from the results.
Early on in the process,
what we call an early epoch,
you'll see static, I mean this is
no better than just random pixels.
And that's because the generator
at the very beginning
doesn't know what it's doing.
It's like, well, have this page
of static and see if that works.
Of course the discriminator,
although not expert yet
is good enough to
determine this is no good.
The middle picture is actually
I think an example of a good example
in the sense that this woman never lived,
but if you looked at
this image, this face,
you might think ah, it's just a lossy JPEG
face of a Swedish woman, not a problem.
And then on the far
right we have an example
of maybe overcompensation
or some kind of mistake
the generator made which
said, I got a face through
with two eyes and one
nose, let me try three eyes
and two noses and see if that works.
I hope to God the discriminator realized
that was not a real
human, but you never know.
So what can we learn from
these, well not much.
These are kind of in the realm of art,
but I think that it is
interesting to compare
ho algorithms come to understand
probability distributions
of RGB pixel values when we ourselves
spend so much time thinking
and looking at these same images.
Looking at the uncanny or horrific
is sometimes a way of casting new light
on the work we do with the authentic.
And I do think there is
possibly some role here
for curators and other professionals
to work with these types of things
at least as ways of
understanding some of the aspects
of the possibilities of machine vision
when it goes off work
and it starts to dream.
Promising areas for the future,
I think that we do need
to appropriate algorithms
from private industry,
I think we need to build
up expertise within
GLAM for machine vision.
I think private partnerships
are also really crucial
but I'd love for if Google came knocking
I'd love for people on
Yale's campus to bring
not only their existing
expertise, but also
some basic knowledge of what
these algorithms can do.
I think combining collections
across institutions
for example reassembling Meserve-Kunhardt
between NPG and Beinecke.
Placing human curatorial
and disciplinary knowledge
as equal partners to machine vision.
We're starting to do some
baby steps towards that
with being able to show metadata facets
in our visualizations,
rearrange to suggest multitude
and complexity rather than
deterministic simplicity
and let you go in with that
lasso and select things
that are meaningful to you.
And finally and most
crucially, if you listen
to one thing I've said today, it's that
institutions such as Yale and Smithsonian
are actually uniquely suited to produce
captioning models, descriptive models
that do match the world of bumblebees,
that do match the 1860s
because we have the excellent
metadata and we have the training data
and all the metadata of the raster pixels
of our own collections,
rather than getting upset
that something is
mischaracterized in an image,
we can retrain the last
layer in these networks
and produce our own 19th century models
of American visual culture, I
think that's very promising.
So with that let me end.
We'll save questions for the lunch.